what's the best Michael Jordan story
what's your best Michael Jordan story uh
well MJ gambles with a good friend of
mine and it's it's crazy it's crazy what
they do he's super competitive I got to
go down and play Grove 23 a couple weeks
ago he was there he kind of hit me from
behind and uh
uh I I actually myself and erlacker won
his last year of his tournament at um at
Shadow Creek
I think we beat uh what then was Bruce
Jenner
Bruce slash Caitlyn they uh he he she
hits the ball far and uh I just said you
know if if if we play again and she's
hitting from the lady Steve we got no
chance
because she because Caitlyn's a good
player too and uh but anyway nice guy
and uh uh but we uh yeah we uh we we got
after him pretty good and won that
tournament and uh but you know just
watching Michael play
um I thought it was really cool when he
was trying to play baseball I think you
know you know we we were we were teasing
them that somebody like that you know if
they got close to facing one of us in
the majors whether it be a devastating
breaking ball or a uh you know a 95 you
know he got the double A and uh we had a
little thing says uh he'd be writing
home to Mom says Dear Mom just saw my
first big league breaking ball P.S be
home soon
but did he have any chance of ever
making it to the majors it wasn't even
no Tebow probably had uh maybe a a
little Edge because just being a
competitive athlete like he is but it's
it's a different deal man it'd be like
you know trying to trying to back pedal
on a fast break with Michael coming at
you you got no chance yeah and uh so
when you hear LeBron saying I may play
for the cowboys stuff like that you
think it's the same thing or you think
LeBron is a different thing he could
actually be a receiver
uh no yeah okay same thought yeah those
guys when if you ever
I mean even in college when you're on
the sidelines and you see a guy coming
around and he he's got the he's got
eight yards to get a first down you see
it and uh the Gap closes in two yards I
mean it's it's crazy how I mean again
the biggest game we had this past year
Alabama came into Austin
and uh first time I met sarc I mean he's
been the man but it was really cool he
said hello to all of his coaches and he
came down he saw me and gave me a hug
and he was he's a huge Red Sox guy so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]